foreign
that's right it's on Australia
commentators we're talking about the
honest trailer for The Super Mario Bros
movie Super Show hosted by us Lon
Spencer Danielle from home why don't you
take a work pipe over here oh right yes
so you don't want me there yeah I don't
have it but someone I was around had it
so I'm being safe to make sure that I we
I'm not a spreader of the Black Death
our Danielle is in another Castle
um but we're here today so we're not
supposed to know where those pipes go
until they're ready to announce the next
franchise you know we we'll be talking
about where this franchise is going and
more and about the honest trailer and um
your comments and questions put those in
the chat and we'll respond to them at
the end along with some outtakes and a
clue for next week's honest trailer
um this week's yeah yeah right I always
forget but it's like yeah okay right the
thing
um this picture's Mario uh damn it
so we're talking Mario which was um I a
fine film I think it like as a lifelong
Nintendo head they had a lot of things
that I recognized so many things yeah I
was doing this a lot yeah a lot of stuff
um from a lot of games and um
beyond that it's a kids movie what can I
say it's like for children the the Mario
goes to the magic land and rescues Luigi
and kicks bows in the face
if you remember the the Super Mario
Brothers Super Show with Captain Lou
Albano and then again now it's time to
go all together now uh so everybody
remembers the live action stuff yeah but
actually they're those live action bits
were bookending cartoons this feels so
much to me like that cartoon I don't
mean this in a bad way that's exactly
what a big animated Mario movie
ought to be yeah but it really did bring
me back that this feels very much like a
classic Saturday morning cartoon of my
youth Vibe just as a movie if it costs
200 million dollars right which fine
good Daniel how are you feeling about
Mario
um I I feel the exact same I thought it
was very cute it's a kids movie it's not
for my 40 year old ass like it's not for
me it's it's it would be weird if it was
it it shouldn't be for me we don't need
a Mario that F's like it's fine you know
like we don't we don't need hardcore
irony Mario this was great it's for the
children they liked it they kept coming
out to it it's fantastic uh like I said
it's it's not for me it's not meant to
be just looking at it as a cute kid
Saturday morning cartoon it is perfectly
fine yeah I liked it more than I like
minions totally and if I was between 7
and 12 this would be my favorite movie
ever granted I would have only seen like
seven movies at that time but this would
be the top of the list yeah
um so yeah I mean if there's not too
much to digest so to speak well I I I do
think one the one other thing I would
say is that it's it's pretty light on a
lot of the stuff that we talk about all
the time that irritates us like that's
the other it it like it does the
Saturday morning thing well it's kind of
fun it's very bright and colorful it
moves very very quickly it's very fast
paced all good things and I like that
there are some we talk about it a little
there's some meta jokes poking fun at
the Mario franchise but it's not
overwhelmed with that stuff there's some
World building and setting up future
franchise installments but it doesn't
feel like the whole movie exists just as
a preview so it's like it's refreshing
in that way and I'll say this it just
looks good like they got the aesthetic
right uh they didn't have to do the
Sonic second draft of like I'm just
kidding yeah a photorealistic teeth on
Mario yeah Diddy Kong looks like he does
in the game no tricks no tricks I think
they learned their lesson well
um and yeah I mean there is more to say
but I think we'll get into it as we
watch the trailer for a Mario
deeply offensive well plus pause
the offensiveness of Mario is something
I want to at least discuss because
people were there really people who were
like you need an Italian person American
to play Mario I said this on Twitter
jokingly okay and a few people did come
and agree with me sincerely so I it was
an idea that was out there it strikes me
a strange because Mario was clearly I
don't know the actual history but it
seems like this was a Japanese person's
idea of what an Italian person might
possibly say a thousand percent right so
in that case are you really gonna claim
Mario as an Italian-American icon I mean
yeah they weren't in Naples coming up
with Mario games like well this was not
like a bunch of Italian people sitting
around like we need to capture most
authentic depiction of our claiming the
the chef outside pizza restaurants a
little porcelain Chef that's holding the
thing like I don't know if you're an
Italian-American sound off is Mario like
a true cultural Touchstone that you need
yeah you need Italian-American voice
over representation Christopher Columbus
and Mario they take these two very
seriously that's it all right let us
know anyways keep going
the first time Nintendo tried to make a
movie things got bad I love the Power
Glove it's so bad and the last time they
tried to adapt Mario thanks God weird
Yoshi is a pet of the royal family just
uh don't move your hands around like a
small wounded animal
now they'll give the minions team a shot
to turn out of the kids flick it was
always meant to be because doing the
most obvious thing possible is why we
love Nintendo in the first place
[Music]
have you played the newest one though he
can throw his hat now
it's super fun so the Super Mario Bro
the only reason I think this movie got
made is because they played it so safe I
think that Nintendo has probably been
approached multiple times by every
single movie studio in Hollywood over
the years to be like please let us make
these into movies please yeah well I
mean I think the the original Super
Mario movie was during an era where it
was just the the Baseline idea was if
you want to take this stuff from other
media comic books or video you have to
like adapt it you have to make it appeal
to people who love movies not people who
play the game right we've got to
translate what people like about this
from the original into something brand
new and then boy did it get new and it
did right and eventually Studios figured
out that's actually not at all what
people want they want exactly what they
like just poured it over to a new you
know format yeah and so yeah I think
they learn their lesson I mean it took
20 years since the last one I mean it's
an 80s movie 30 right 30. it's mid 90s
yeah early 90s yeah so I think they were
really burned by that um by that
experience and it probably took an
entirely new generation of of employees
and Executives at Nintendo before
they're like we should try making a
movie again yeah and I think it worked
for this well we'll get into it later
let's keep watching the trailer
other super movie okay say hello to
Mario and Luigi the original Super Mario
Brothers oh we're the Mario brothers and
plumbings again we're not led to others
who get all the fame now say goodbye
because Luigi spends the whole movie as
a hostage
watch comic Dynamo Charlie Day hang out
in a cage waiting to be rescued while
funny enough Chris Pratt repeatedly
bails him out of trouble
Mario
and Dave me around I'm like probably the
weirdest guy in the universe you know
probably even weirder than someone from
Saturn
I think that one missed opportunity One
Missed opportunity was you didn't have
to have Luigi a hostage like in a cage
just completely passive the whole time
put him in a mansion right full of goats
it was right there they're already doing
it and then they they're doing it they
remove him from that setting it is weird
because it is so slavishly trying to
redo the games in so many ways and
that's not Mario and Luigi fight
alongside each other it's not about
rescuing Luigi and I get that they
didn't want to do rescue the princess
fine good but I don't it's weird that
they just flipped in another character
to be rescued I feel like people want to
see them on an adventure together not
one is saving the other end you're still
saving him just from a haunted mansion
well it could just be the weird vacuum
cleaner you know it sucks but you just
you don't need that plot wise it could
just be we gotta save the Mushroom
Kingdom from you don't even need to be
we gotta rescue my brother I don't think
yeah I mean to the degree that there is
characterization in this movie it's like
just make up another
yeah device and then I think they
literally forgot Mario's character Arc
at the end because Mario like has to
find his courage at the end it's like I
gotta stand up and like that's never
been Mario's problem like I think you're
thinking of Luigi you kind of got them
switched at the end it's fine this is
for eight year olds yeah it doesn't
really hold yeah keep going
that's Andy Dwyer in parks and rec so
now we're stuck with Chris Pratt for all
eternity watch the Chris most likely to
do his own research reprise his
trademark role as a lone human bouncing
around an alien world listening to Dad
rock as he becomes Mario an icon to both
Italians and Gamers because he's a hero
who still lives at home with his mom
he'll join up with Peach and honest to
goodness toilet baby who was flushed
into the Mushroom Kingdom one day and
somehow became the mother of fungus she
grew into a princess who's on board with
the concept of monarchy but won't accept
a marriage to save her kingdom because
she can't shake her mean case of human
savior syndrome
let him
I know they've answered this uh
canonically in other Mario media where
like she has parents like King Toad and
stuff like that yeah yeah but in this
movie I think it's like establishing a
new timeline where are your parents
that's not how monarchy Works you're the
princess yeah it's weird that she's a
princess and not a queen right uh it's
also like it's just like they never put
her back in the pipe like maybe her
parents are waiting for her on the other
push the baby but if a baby crawls out
of your pipes just turn it around
you would think they would try like and
we went through the pipe and look for
her parents but they were gone like
there's not even an attempt it's just a
baby wander down here like well you live
here he's our princess now I guess like
girls go to the Mushroom Kingdom and
boys become lost boys they go to
Neverland they say once they get flushed
I don't know
yeah
um these These are the really important
questions which is like devastated
parents and queens whose baby just
disappeared one night and they like
never got any answers well this is this
is material for the sequel yeah the
search for Peach's parents actually they
I think that was prom night you know it
could have been prom night I don't know
oh no oh wow oh no
Danielle oh you are dark but no they did
they did set that up right I feel like
the search for peach is true origin is
going to play into like whatever sets up
Smash Bros yeah they're gonna go looking
for it and they're gonna be like Samus
what Star Fox what are you doing here
um Gabby J that's the first guy you
fight in punch up what
um yeah it writes itself all right keep
going
aren't you he's not important
I'll never let anyone ruin this well
excuse me princess there's a million
toads and only one of you get a grip and
along for the ride our Toad and Donkey
Kong portrayed by two comedians whose
voices are so unique they must be used
in everything forever
easy money
standing in their way is Bowser who asks
us to imagine what if Jack Black was
himself I'll make you you mine he's got
a fiendish plan to go viral on Tick Tock
peaches peaches peaches peaches peaches
and with the Tenacious D front man now
part of Star Wars Nintendo and Weird Al
universes all in the same year can every
other franchise be far behind
[Music]
me
uh yeah I mean Jack Black is he's our
current and I mean this isn't his first
wave but he's now got to be probably the
most beloved celebrity he's taken like
that Crown I feel like it's it's maybe
not most overall but like the widest age
range like if you are four to 44 you
love you love Jack Black like I remember
him from my youth nostalgically but then
the kids also love it yeah yeah I don't
know if that if a lot of other people
have that rain no there's been multiple
Jack Black arrows and I I've struggled
to think of anyone
um like I think people like I don't know
Tom Hanks or something like that well
yeah I mean like like Will Smith up
until a few years ago I feel like would
have been the big competition because
kids loved Will Smith
I feel like it's been a while since Will
Smith's done anything for the young ones
yeah that's true it's a lot of
emancipation level stuff recently and
the kids aren't into it so yeah like
Oscar Chasers yeah I really like I feel
like they really don't want they don't
want to see movies that are just to win
Oscars when he was still doing like wild
wild west type stuff then yeah I would
have been him but King Richard not as
much
gosh yeah good great performance yeah
I don't know uh keep you keep going I'm
I'm peeking ahead of your questions
they're actually very good I wish this
was clearly meant for
enjoy the action that feels like
watching someone else play a video game
embrace yourself for the Cinematic
Universe it's trying to jump start
there's a huge Universe out there with a
lot of galaxies yeah
here's my issue with this is I think
that this I think they pulled off Mario
about as well as you could hope for
someone to pull off Mario but the the
drive to expand this I don't think you
can make a Zelda movie at this tone for
no like purely for kids I think Zelda
they're gonna they're gonna try to do
like live Metroid I don't think you can
do it for kids no I think it's more like
yeah you could do Kirby you could do
Kirby gone country there's a lot of
those and I think you build this to
Smash Bros this is this is this is
inevitably leading to Smash Bros and do
they do the
um you know the the non-aggression
agreement if not like sharing pact where
they do team up Mario and Sonic and
Pikachu and stuff like that like I think
they'd be Fool's not they'd be fools
like Sonic is in Smash Bros yeah I think
I think at some point Nintendo does a
few of these and then they have to get
the Pokemon company and Sega on the horn
and be like we've got it we got an event
across the street yeah we gotta cross
these streets yeah but I do think that
money is because yeah Ash and Ash and
Pikachu for sure gotta gotta eventually
be in here yeah but I do think that the
other huge one is you know certainly the
gaming world is Zelda and I don't think
you could make a Zelda movie unless you
did full excuse me princess style
um of the same tone and same everything
no I I mean they're they you know there
was all that talk like last decade about
like maybe we'll get like Peter Jackson
or guiller Del Toro and like I feel like
that would be the smart egg like get a
big fan what are you doing
give them 200 million dollars Chris
Pratt is the voice no I don't think
voice I think you do live action Zelda
personally but I agree they're mute
doesn't talk well in our movie link
talks oh I'm sorry okay no no I will not
allow it it's not like an old like
Master Chief where he can't take his
helmet off he's like he's a guy they can
only grunt elishly
he just has a fairy that talks to him
the whole time Aquafina and she just
never stops
oh another dungeon huh a lot of those
yeah all the dialogue should just be
text boxes scrolling text boxes that pop
up and the whole audience has to press a
to keep going when they're ready wait
that's just the game keep going
aimed at the next generation of Nintendo
Land ticket buyers
but if you're an adult seriously
invested in the quality of a Mario movie
well they put someone in this movie Just
For You everything's over now and all
that's left is you and the infinite
voice
story
I don't know what an Italian accent is
and at this point I'm too afraid to ask
Casey Affleck the teachers of peaches
you know I could eat a peach for hours
it's a stool sample do a barrel roll
retirement to the Planet of the Apes
your average Mario Maker level
s
character formerly known as look it up
and Einstein rosenbridge thanks Thor
what you seek it's a bridge
more like a Rainbow Bridge micro dosing
and more slow-mo than Zack Snyder
directing a Max Payne movie
[Music]
Super Cash Bros
Mario and Luigi are officially the best
characters to defend Brooklyn and
e-mushrooms the competition wasn't that
Fierce though I think that I may be the
voice of my generation
girls would be an interesting rewatch oh
right wait we should that's the pilot
yeah and she called called her shot she
nailed it I would love to re-watch uh
girls and see how that holds up even
even you know fascinating would be the
Adam Driver yeah that would be what I'd
be interested in like now remember
peeing on her yeah now that we know what
driver would become it'd be fascinating
to go watch like driver Origins yeah
driver Origins yeah uh all right well
thanks for watching to this point we
still have lots more including on this
very same channel we figured out who
Hollywood's best Chris is numerically
um speaking of Hemsworth he's uh he's in
the Hemsworth V Pine V Pratt V uh Evans
yeah we all have our personal favorites
but we used you know their fighting
stats their romantic stats the critical
box office stuff so yeah a lot of
different factors go check out who
Hollywood's best Chris is 2023 as we say
this will change because they all make
100 movies a year they're inescapable
the Christmas ghosted is gonna really
throw off this whole thing
so uh yeah like And subscribe if you
haven't already and uh we have some
honest trailer outtakes for you let's
see what we cut
hit the pie for 2023's wildest room trip
for kids in this movie packed with
bright colored hyperkinetic action for
eight-year-olds and old school gaming
references for the old farts does this
thing work you just have to blow into it
in this genuine celebration of a classic
property that avoids looking down on its
source material and what
okay every movie gets one Farmers
wearing bike clubs okay so these bricks
are just floating here or three
Mario why do
whatever what is this is this okay look
it's 20 23. the IP shame is still well
below average
story
it's a hymn blob Hoskins Pratt Falls
Green Day I Know Why the Caged nerd
sings Pig the crown Battle Royal Gideon
Pig Salonga Bowser
fungi Mr Toad wild guide MF shrew banana
Express Diary of a kitty kid the Apes of
Wrath
Crank Yankers Harry David Curb Your
Enthusiasm
Roblox
Mario teaches piping
Nintendo Atlanta Universal give out
fresh rooms because that's the only way
to fully enjoy the Water World stunt
show
yeah we fit many references to that
stunt showing us over the years I love
what it used to be I blame myself before
it was the water world show it was the
Miami Vice action spectacular which also
ended with a plane a biplane yeah
jumping in you can reuse that they just
reskinned it I love that so much yeah
change everyone out of Hawaiian shirts
yeah and Blazers
fishnets and football pads that's why
it's still the water realtor they just
can't they haven't come up with a new
movie to reskin the plane jumping come
on Uncharted please do better Universal
this way
pitching filmmakers like could a biplane
jump over something and crash in your
movie there is like a John Peterson a
giant spider yeah yeah that's the new
giant spiders like we really we gotta do
something with this spectacular
uh all right moving on to your questions
um thank you for submitting these Adam
Holbert writes uh where are we at with
Pratt now not a Mario fan but somehow he
was okay to decent in Guardians 3 or is
that just because gun is a really good
director so where's your Chris Pratt
um uh cue score these days
he's inevitable so he's the Thanos of
comic actors yeah he's around right like
he doesn't I don't hate him there are
people out there who really just hate
him and that I can see there being a lot
of like solid reasons for why one might
want to do so I don't hate him he's fine
him being in a movie is not going to
stop me from going to go see that movie
yeah but it's also because I want to be
able to see any movie all year and it
could be any of them at any time he's
like Tyler Perry he just shows up yeah
yeah I I find him sort of personally
irritating like when there's like a
viral Instagram thing he wrote I'm
always like but I don't mind him in move
like I think he's fine in movies like
not every movie but like in something
like this or in Guardians like it
doesn't bother me with these in there I
think play it is playing to his
strengths to be uh you know this kind of
adorkable goof with abs or without but I
think when he tries to do like uh like
tomorrow War I think was that yeah that
one doesn't really I have yet to see
anything else work besides his like Andy
Dwyer Star-Lord like yeah he's got the
other side which is like where he plays
like badass military got like zero dog
an office gym like it's just not working
you guys yeah you can't spend that long
on a Mike Shore show and then yeah
turned into a hardcore badass uh yeah I
don't know if he really pulls it off um
all right so uh let's see uh Bruins fan
1144 instead of making games into movies
what movie would make a good game I
think Battlestar Galactica would make a
great Mass effect-esque game yeah battle
Circle that goes great I would watch
that yeah well ironically I was gonna
say Dune because that's just my go-to
answer for everything but Dune was the
first real-time strategy game
I haven't played it there are Dune I
think there was a newer Dune game too
right I think they came out with a okay
not not directly tied into the movie but
yeah there was like an open world RPG
that I signed up for and have yet to
hear right yeah there was some other
Dune game in the offing they were
talking about I think a dune like like a
grand strategy Dune game like a more of
like a map based you know you you
position your like risk or something
that was with like more more scepter
fudge or whatever yeah uh yeah I would
do a a big Dune one but
I don't know I think what about
skinamarink the game no no the menu like
a really popular indie horror game
though it's like you're watching yeah
different old tapes right and like you
press a button to like run away from all
right from the phone I was joking but
you've convinced me now that it could
work
Danielle you got one oh yeah I just said
the menu of the game oh the menu of the
game yeah like a cooking mama like
Rhythm
each course has kind of a different
genre yeah like cooking simulator mixed
with survival horror yeah maybe or
something I like that
um let's see so uh Pericles Dragon Balls
asked what other uh video game movies
could use a Super Mario Bros movie style
do-over like let's redo oh let's redo a
bad video game movie
um I think you know what I think if you
did if you took the approach of the 90s
Street Fighter movie today I think
audiences might be more into it like I
think it was a little weak like people
in the 90s didn't get that they were
joking and thought this was the sincere
movie and they were like what the hell
is this but I think today that sort of
parody voice might play better because
people have a more ironic sense of humor
I would think like a like a Double
Dragon remake I think you could
definitely do like a good Kung Fu like
street fight and beat em up
um whereas uh God I don't even remember
that I just remember it being bad it's
bad yeah the other one I was gonna say I
just thought of was a silent hill
because I think I could use another
crack yeah they just it just didn't
didn't turn out that good but what an
atmospheric cool setting I'm sure a lot
of filmmakers would have fun recreating
Silent Hill on the big screen they were
a little too we gotta re do levels right
you know like it's too much like the
game you should have did that one you
can you can pivot I think so you got one
Danielle how's the dead how's the dead
sure no no how could you take take away
but gets to do it yeah exactly yes skim
a bigger budget
um Samuel Furman he was thinking along
the same lines as us since you know the
Zelda movie can't be far off should they
break with the franchise by having link
talk or try to make a 90-minute movie
around a mute protagonist mute
protagonist mute protagonist you can't
have Zelda talk come on I mean I mean
link talk how dare I you the only way to
do it would be like Zelda's with him for
the whole mission yeah but I mean to me
that that messes with the formula more
than having him talk he's got a Goron
he's got a Zora he's got a whole gang
around him that can that can speak on
his behalf all right I I know I think
that's weird but okay
uh Evan Jay princess says I'm invested
now what does lon's shirt say oh this is
the official like if you want to support
the strike uh this is one of the
official shirts that you can buy that
actually donates to it's not just some
guy on Redbubble made it uh it says wga
and sag and IAT and teamsters and DJ all
the all the entertainment unions
hopefully are gonna get together
hopefully where yeah when did we find
out about sag in the direction uh the
the go associations actually have to
happen those are happening in June but I
believe the actors have voted to
authorize a strike if if they don't if
the negotiations don't work out the the
negotiators on sagside have the
authority to call for a struggle yeah
all right well here's to open well we
don't hope for a strike we hope for to
be resolved with everyone right I hope
we hope everybody gets paid what they
deserve yeah uh Evan Jay Prince girl
right
Mario was inspired by Nintendo's
landlord at the time if you made a game
based on one of your landlords what
would it be is that true is that
established I guess so I I mean I'm
taking his word for is he Italian but it
must been yeah an Italian plumber owned
a bunch of property in Japan yeah any
landlord-based games you could throw at
us oh oh
landlord games that sense I don't want
to play that uh-uh yeah they'd be all
very absentee in my case they'd be like
missing like something's wrong Brian I
feel like a lot of 80s a lot of classic
arcade games were like this like you
like Burger Time where it's like you
just have a job like make these Burgers
go yeah so be like manage these
buildings
uh let's see we got some we got some
good stuff here uh Tanner back and Rex
uh do any of us have a letterbox account
it would be fun to see reviews lists Etc
from all of us on there Danielle you're
on letterbox
um I opened one I don't think I've done
a single review on it um I'll be honest
part of the reason I didn't is because I
was because very like on his letterbox
and people started using that as a way
to like ask about future trailers and
stuff like that and I was like I don't
need that in my life yeah that sounds
like a lot I I just I'm really like
I know I should do it and it'd be cool
and I probably would enjoy it but it to
start it it sounds like such a huge
ordeal like I would have to start
cataloging every movie I've seen like
that's that's that's two thousands
that's tens of thousands it would just
never be complete and it would be one of
those things that would always be in my
like I should update my letterbox and I
was like I don't need this in my life
yeah I got enough stuff that I worry
about falling behind on without adding a
new one fair fair enough I'm on there as
Spenny G I haven't posted since December
uh but uh when I you know I think it's
actually like yeah all of my posts are
like December January so I think when I
when I start watching the Oscar movies I
was vlogging those and stuff but like if
I had to go back for every movie I
watched over the last four months you
don't have to I watched like a bunch of
movies a week you know like I that's a
lot of updating so I'll try to I'll try
to throw throw a bone in there once in a
while I'm not gonna do like a preview on
his trailers whatever it's the the stuff
I've done is like the Lost daughter and
and like the last little banshees to
finish here and like these aren't the
honest trailer movies you're looking for
but uh but I am on there
um and then let's see my Tim fleshy says
how long until we hear something about
the metal gear movie starring Oscar
Isaac directed by friend of the show
Jordan Voit Roberts yeah what the hell I
want to see that movie yeah I that's one
of those projects where man it's been a
long time since we've had any updates
I'm starting to get a little a little
nervous that we might get an update
that's like yeah that ain't happening
Oscar's busy I mean Oscar is busy I I'm
really I'm hoping and looking forward to
that I like a lot of those people in
that that'd be incredible perfect so
yeah yeah all right
um we'll be back next week
um I'm thinking we're thinking we're
back next week there's your clue uh see
if you can
see that's why link would work
um and we'll we'll be back next week for
John Wick 4. thanks for watching
[Music]
I'm thinking